I PROMISE.
I’M GOING TO DO MY PART.
AND THAT IS "THE ANGLE."
NOW THE BIG NEWS OF THE DAY WAS
DR. FAUCI AND FRIENDS RETURNING
TO CAPITOL HILL.
20 MADE NOW TO BREAK IT ALL DOWN
DOWN, DR. RAMIN ASKOUI
CARDIOLOGIST AND CEO OF FOX
CARDIOLOGY AND DR. STEPHEN SMITH
FOUNDER OF THE SMITH CENTER FOR
INFECTIOUS DISEASES AND URBAN
HEALTH.
GUYS MIGHT WANT TO START OFF
WITH DR. FAUCI TAKING AIM AT A N
STUDY SHOWING POSITIVE RESULTS F
>> IN A HOSPITAL STUDY THAT WAS
PUBLISHED WAS IN NONCONTROLLED
RETROSPECTIVE COHORT STUDY THAT
OF ISSUES INCLUDING THE FACT
THAT MANY OF THE PEOPLE
RECEIVING HYDROXYCHLOROQUINE
WILL ALSO RECEIVING STEROIDS.
SO THAT STUDY IS A FLAWED STUDY
AND ANYONE WHO EXAMINES IT
CAREFULLY IS IT IS NOT A
RANDOMIZED PLACEBO-CONTROLLED
TRIAL.
I DON’T HAVE ANY COURSE IN THE
GAME ONE WAY OR THE OTHER.
I JUST LOOK AT THE DATA.
>> Laura: DR. SMITH, HE JUST
LOOKED AT THE DATA.
WAS THE STUDY FLAWED AND WHAT
ABOUT WHAT DR. FAUCI SAID?
>> WE KNOW IT IS NOT A
RANDOMIZED STUDY.
AND IT WAS A RANDOMIZED
CONTROLLED BUT THEY DID CONTROL
THE EXPOSURE AND STILL
HYDROXYCHLOROQUINE HEAD
BENEFITS.
BUT THE BIGGER PROBLEM IS
DR. FAUCI HAS TAKEN AIM AT THE
STUDY FOR NOT BEING RANDOMIZED
CONTROLLED STUDY WHERE HE’S
ENDORSED OTHER STUDIES THAT ALSO
WERE THE MORE OBSERVATIONS THAT
OF COURSE, WAS FRAUD.
IN ALL THESE OTHER STUDIES, HE
NAMED THEM, THEY HAVE TO HAVE TO
BE IN CONTROLLED STUDIES AND
THERE AREN’T THAT MANY
RANDOMIZED.
SO IT’S DISTURBING.
AND THERE ARE CONTROLLED
STUDIES, EVEN THE FIRST
NEUROLOGICAL STUDY WAS
CONTROLLED AND RAN TO MY SO GOOD
CONTROLS AND ACTUALLY LESS THEN
THE DRUG RECEIVING PATIENTS.
THE DRUG RECEIVING PATIENTS WITH
THE VIRUS QUICKER.
THE PLACEBO STUDIES IN INDIA
COME AGAIN NOT RANDOMIZED, BUT
THE MORE CONTROLS, DECIDED NOT
TO TAKE HYDROXYCHLOROQUINE.
THESE STUDIES ARE CONTROLLED AND
ON TOP OF IT, IF I REMEMBER
CORRECTLY, AND DR. FAUCI WAS MY
MENTOR AND I APPRECIATE WHAT HE
DID FOR ME.
THEY PUBLISHED THEIR BIG
FINDINGS BACK IN THE EARLY
’70s IN AN UNCONTROLLED STUDY
WITH -- WHICH WORKS AND I CREDIT
THAT WITH THEM.
SO YOU GOT TO LOOK AT AT THE
SAME WAY.
>> Laura: SO IT TURNS OUT, LET
ME JUMP IN HERE, IT TURNS OUT
DR. ASKOUI DR. ASKOUI, DR. FAUCI
DOESN’T BELIEVE THAT THESE
RANDOMIZED CONTROLLED STUDIES
ARE ALWAYS NECESSARY, BUT FOR SO
REASON, THEY ARE NECESSARY IN
THE MIDDLE OF A PANDEMIC WHERE
WE HAVE HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
PEOPLE DYING IN A SITUATION
WHERE PEOPLE WANT ANSWERS AND
REALISTIC HOPE.
NO ONE IS SAYING IT’S A PANACEA
OR ANYTHING LIKE THAT.
BUT WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THAT
TESTIMONY TODAY, SPECIFICALLY ON
THAT.
ANY OTHER THOUGHTS?
>> WELCOME UNFORTUNATELY WHAT I
THINK STEVE HAS ULTIMATELY
POINTED OUT, LYING BY OMISSION
IS STILL LYING.
IT IS VERY IMPORTANT TO
UNDERSTAND THAT STUDY DID
CORRECT STEROID USE BUT IT ALSO
POINTED OUT WHAT WE SEEM TO SEE
IN COVID WHICH IS A STEROID
PARADOX WHERE IF YOU HAVE A
DISEASE A MILD DISEASE, STEROIDS
DON’T HELP YOU WHERE IS IF YOU
HAVE A MORE STAIR -- SEVERE
DISEASE, GREATER THAN 20, STEROI
SPECIFICALLY MAY BE IMMENSELY
HELPFUL.
AND WHAT I’M HEARING IS SOMEONE
WHO IS FRANKLY VERY MANIPULATIVE
AND DISHONEST AS A SCIENTIST.
>> Laura: SO THE CDC COMPLETED
AN INVESTIGATION ON COVID
TRANSMISSION, THEY OBSERVED IT
AS SLEEP AWAY CAMP WITH KIDS AT
COUNSELORS AND SEVERE -- WITH
THE STUDY BUT THE CDC CONCLUDED
THAT THE BODY OF EVIDENCE
DEMONSTRATING THAT CHILDREN OF
ALL AGES ARE SO ACCEPTABLE TO
SOURCE COVID TO COME INFECTION
TO EARLY REPORTS MIGHT PLAY AN
IMPORTANT ROLE IN TRANSMISSION.
DR. ASKOUI, WHAT DOES THAT TELL
YOU, SHOULD WE RUN FROM SCHOOLS
AND KEEP HER KIDS LOCKED IN THE
HOUSE?
>> NO I THINK IT MEANS WE SHOULD
BELIEVE OUR LYING EYES.
KIDS SIMPLY DON’T GET THAT SICK.
WE ARE NOT SEEING WARDS, ICU,
PEDIATRICS HOSPITALS FULL OF
KIDS ON VENTILATORS.
WHEN CHILDREN GET COVID,
PROBABLY MORE RELIABLY TEST
POSITIVE FOR RNA FRAGMENTS OF
COVID AND THEY SIMPLY DON’T GET
THAT SICK.
THIS IS THE IDEA THAT KIDS IN
PERSON SCHOOLS AND THEY NEED TO
GO FIVE DAYS A WEEK.
AND WE NEED TO SHOW THEM THE
ROAD JUST LIKE THEY ARE DOING IN
SWEDEN AND OTHER EUROPEAN
COUNTRIES.
>> Laura: HERE IS ANOTHER
POINT, DR. SMITH, NANCY PELOSI
IS OFTEN SAYING LOOK WE NEED TO
LISTEN TO THE SCIENTIST.
NOT SCIENTIST ACTUALLY TREATING
PATIENTS, BUT SCIENTIST, BUT
BEHIND THE SCENES, WE FOUND OUT
SOMETHING DIFFERENT.
SHE REPORTED REPORTEDLY SAID TO
STEVEN MNUCHIN AND WHITE HOUSE
STAFF MARK MEADOWS THAT DR. BIRX
IS THE WORST, WOW WHAT HORRIBLE
HAND YOU ARE IN CLOSE HE SAID.
SO I GUESS IF YOU DON’T PREEN
FOR THE CAMERA AND POSED FOR
"PEOPLE" MAGAZINE, PELOSI
TRASHES YOU?
WHAT ABOUT THAT?
>> THE WHOLE THING IS
UNBELIEVABLE, AGAIN, DR. FAUCI
IS RIGHT THAT WE HAVE TO LOOK AT
DATA.
THAT IS CORRECT AND WE HAVE TO
LOOK AT DATA FAIRLY.
AND THAT HAS NOT BEEN DONE.
AND TO DEMONIZE PEOPLE BASICALLY
FROM THEIR INTERPRETATION OF THE
DATA IS UNBELIEVABLY WRONG.
I JUST CAN’T GET OVER THE
RESPONSE TO A DRUG THAT IS SO
SAFE AND DOESN’T WORK.
DOESN’T WORK.
>> Laura: GENTLEMEN YOU’VE HAD
BEEN TO BOYS MIKE VOICES ARE